if he was addressed in nowadays you'll
see it restored to its former glory a
baroque beauty on the river over
outer begins with a stroll along the
blue terrace and a slight detour to a
Kostas closet to see the first and sook
or procession of princes this large
ceramic mural depicts past rulers of
Saxony including our coasters the strong
who played a key role in shaping the
face of Dresden in the early 18th
century he commissioned magnificent
baroque buildings such as the swinger
Palace one of Dresden's most famous
landmarks this is where the parents held
lavish banquets for his guests the
palace houses one of the world's most
impressive collections of porcelain gilt
paneling and brightly painted walls
provide a backdrop for the porcelain as
they did back in the days of Augustus
the strong the ruins of the Church of
Our Lady once served as a warning
against the horrors of war now restored
the church is a symbol of reconciliation
attending a service where the organist
played is a lovely way to enjoy the
interior you can also climb up to the
Dome of the church you'll be rewarded
with a stunning view the ubertino
art museum dates back to the Renaissance
era it's been thoroughly restored and
houses the city sculpture collection and
the new masters gallery the Albertina
features works from the Romantic period
to the present day by world famous
artists among them yahar Cristo after a
tour of Dresden's museums a ride on a
traditional paddle steamer is an ideal
way to relax chugging up and down the
river ever while taking in the scenery
the leisurely boater takes you past
palaces vineyards and villas
or you can take to the air in one of
Dresden's cable cars opened in 1901 the
system is thought to be the oldest of
its kind in the world
and you round off the day was a
panoramic view of the air Beverly and
Tristan
you